you
everyone is Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics train I'm going to try three
more puzzles and just share my thoughts
along the way so this one it's white to
move okay hmm
what's the big trick with this okay
well doing a quick material count were
even and my first thought is that there
should be something against this Queen
hmm
this Bishop move moving the knight in
other words with an attack on the Queen
but moving the knight with care because
he has a job currently to watch over the
main thread on g2 about the bishop and
Queen converging so there aren't any all
hang on actually there's a checking move
don't know what that's going to amount
to my first thought really wasn't the
check but rather Knight here which
interferes with the mate threat on g2
and throws a punch at the Queen now what
more is this Knight doing that this
Knight move doing it's a question I have
I don't know if I have a good answer to
that Knight to d5 tax the Queen but what
more is the knight really doing hmm okay
oh I see another idea okay I think I
have another idea which is moving the
Knight to g4 okay there's these I think
the idea is to move the knight and the
bishop this queen is as indirect as it
may be she's attacking the knight I can
move out of the way with the bishop and
give check so I clear one piece so that
the Queen is attacking e5 and so in
other words if I play Knight g4 that
still prevents a mate threat on g2 it
also tax the knight
attacks the Queen and the Queen has to
move to a square where she's still
watching over the night so in other
words Knight g4 Queen let's say f5 and
now Knight takes Knight and if Queen
takes Knight
then there's Bishop to b5 check and I'd
be winning the Queen so I think that's
it Knight g4 any other candidate moves
not so sure this is quite forcing not
the most forcing but you know if there
isn't to check that next most forcing
move is an attack against the Queen
especially if that Queen is unprotected
so Knight g4 I believe is going to be at
Knight g4 there is this check but you
just could take same story around the
Queen so I'm pretty sure it's Knight g4
the Queen moves you take the knight and
if the Queen recaptures you give that
check so I'm gonna just run with it okay
that is it
Queen a five is it am I missing anything
there's pressure on f2 but there's
enough defenders just winning a piece
Knight takes e5 that is correct and this
is it
so Bishop check and at the end of it
picking up the Queen that should be it
all right let's try another one problem
two of three okay you play black it says
alright what to say with this alright
this Knight is pinned my first thought
is not to take the knight but rather
maybe put more pressure on the pinned
piece there is Queen to h2 it's check
Queen h2 is a check move Bishop takes
Knight this is probably the only useful
checking move by the Queen hmm
Queen h2 check and then aren't we just
picking up the night next this King
isn't going to be in any danger of
checks like the only potential check is
Knight to f4 but after Queen h2 and a
king move actually what am I even
talking about after Queen h2 and the
King moves here which is the only move
the bishops watching over f1 then just
Bishop takes Knight with's check oh no
no no hang on there's coverage of this
Knight twice with the rook and Queen I
was blind to seeing the Queen is also
there to watch over the night so hang on
for a second Queen to age two King D one
oh there could be another cheque thrown
in clean h2 King he won there could now
be Queen to g1 check which would force
King to d2 and then
there might be a little king walk over
here might be something to that if the
King ends up on the C file and um I'm
going too deep here probably if the king
is walking all the way over here and
gets to the C file one of these C
squares the rook could come over but
then there's always a night block so I'm
starting to discount that let me let me
go right back to square one here Queen
h2 seems like the first move let me give
one brief thought to this Bishop takes
Knight rook takes okay not sure what the
follow-up is after that Queen h2 King e1
clean g1 check let's try it again Queen
h2 Keeney one Bishop takes Knight rook
takes and mmm there might be something
with the rook coming in to h2 at some
point Queen h2 king e1 queen g1 King d2
queen - f - check
hmm King to see one or there'll even be
a night block right there
I feel like I'm close but I'm not seeing
it very clearly at all huh aged to King
D one kingi one King to D 2
huh I'm not sure on this one
Queen each to Keaney one Queen to g1
check what else is unprotected I mean
this
there's no I didn't even do a body count
here you could do a piece count
okay black is up upon really a big deal
but regarding unprotected pieces okay
he's protected everything seems to be
decently protected on the white side so
I'm not seeing some way to let's say
exploit an unprotected piece hmm Chuck
King here Queen check on g1 King to d2
Queen to f2 check I don't know that I'm
gonna get this one I might have to just
run with it and play it along enough
I'll be able to see it through to its
end but maybe I could see it at a
certain point I'm gonna I'm just gonna
try it
Queen h2o I spent enough time on this
one alright that is the first move and I
wasn't really thinking that this is
gonna be a thinking check I'm gonna go
with the Queen check no that's incorrect
I guess it's Bishop takes Knight mm-hmm
let's go to the would see the solution
bishop takes what's the follow up after
rook takes
oh my goodness
oh man I probably got very loud right
there what can you do
oh my goodness why was I so focused on
these zigzag moves with my queen
oh that seems so basic ah man what can
you do oh my goodness I was talking
about yeah if he gets over here on the C
file quit thinking too deep check King
here take a knight and then made on this
square huh let me I wonder why I
overlooked that I wonder why I was so
blind to this e 2 square hmm
actually I think the reason for this is
because from this current position
there's two pieces guarding this e2
square you could even reason 1/3 the
king but from this current position the
rook and the knight are there but in
this variation right here right from the
beginning Queen age 2 you take out one
defender of this square and well really
with that caps
you're removing two pieces from the e2
square and I was just completely blind
to it clean it to me
ouch okay well that was that was tough
for me clearly removing two defenders
from that e 2 square wasn't visualizing
it well enough that he could be removing
those guys from the e 2 square
all right let's see if I could try and
get this last one problem three all
right team white I feel like I've had
this problem before yeah I think I might
have encountered this problem before um
okay well my first thought is to just
pick up the bishop how are we doing
piecewise here piecewise we're looking
at wiping down a ruck this Knight is not
going to contribute so it's up to the
bishop the two bishops and the Queen
there's a check on g5 a3 and g7 hmm okay
if Bishop checks here then the King
could run here that's probably not it so
let's forget about Bishop 83 at least
for right now and this I was thinking
just sharing my thoughts of course
Bishop Bishop
a3 I was thinking the knight would have
to block but no he could just go to f6
so I'm down to these two Queen check and
Bishop takes Bishop if Bishop takes
Bishop the knight must block oh I see it
okay Bishop takes Bishop and after the
knight blocks you just take the knight
the pawn can't recapture because it's
pinned so therefore the king must take
and then the king and queen are lined up
which allows Queen h4 picking up
Queen well that seems very clean I think
very nervous now it's like when you saw
that when I saw that little red color
come up and correct got a little nervous
I don't want that to happen again
I was shooting for green go for green
here Bishop takes Bishop it's all pretty
forcing Knight blocks you just take the
knight another check
and then another check picking up the
Queen one last thing to actually check
for that variation I'm pretty sure
that's it is that the king is not on a
light square at the end of this
variation where you pick up the Queen if
the bishop was able to move and in some
way and give check then you'd be losing
the Queen back but that's not quite the
case here of course so let's just see
the green all right take the knight and
then finally give a check and get that
Queen all right
two out of three that a second one was
uh gotta say you can't hear it in my
voice but it's very painful but uh
clearly it happens
alright well as always I hope you got
something out of this video take care
bye
you